こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
はい
オレンジに
エレベーターがつきましたー
[拍手]
1年以上かかった静岡のはじめしゃちょー
の3億円のお家ずっといろいろ改造したり
メンテナンスしたりこう直したり付け足し
たりしてきました空調を直したり照明を
直したりインターネットが消えたところを
直したりとかようやくおそらく3億円のお
家でもう必ず
体重移動と言ってもいいくらい大切なこの
家には欠かせないものエレベーターが
ようやく完成いたしました
仮にさーん
[音楽]
このお家の
ヒッチトマトの最終最重要項目といっても
いいのではないでしょうかそうですね
エレベーターが完成したということでお
答えいたしましたありがとうございます
期間っていうとですねあの一番最初に
見積もりもらった時の日付を見るとですね
2021年の11月って書いてあります
[音楽]
実際は9月からあったあっそうなんですね
だいたいまあ2ヶ月くらい2ヶ月ぐらい
やっぱりねあのものがやっぱりどうしても
入ってこないエレベーター本体がなるほど
ね
半導体のせいですねちょっとだって普通家
にエレベーターねえもんそうなんだよ最近
嫁ちゃんとはどう
急だなこれなんかほんと工事自体は始まっ
て1ヶ月ぐらいからねそうだね
工事の音うるさくて僕結構東京に逃げてた
んですけども
結構かなり大きな工事をしてもらって1
ヶ月ぐらいかな大体パパパってやって
もらってエレベーターが
民間の人間の王子に着きましたはいという
わけでさん何も知らないままエレベーター
直しといてって言ったんですけどあの気に
なる金額みたいなところあると思うんです
けども
確かに気になりますね
値段によっては3億円じゃなくて4億円に
なる可能性もあるかなと思います今んとこ
3億3000万ぐらいに
なってるので
気になるエレベーターのお値段みたいなと
ころってどれぐらいなんですかね気になる
お値段はいお願いします
ズバリはい
757万円でございます
[音楽]
757万円か
いやまあまあ普通に考えて
ちっちゃなお部屋が移動するわけですから
やけど正直を4階建てのこんだけ大きい家
に住んでみて1年間ぐらい思ったのがここ
今4階なんですけども1回から4回の上り
券ももちろんないんですけどもそれは別に
いいんですよ
普通のことじゃない1回金4階
物運ぶ時がもう
本当にきつくて結構そこでここ1年間この
家で萎えてたことがあったのでそれが今回
このエレベーターに着いたということで
持つ運びかなり楽になったと思います
[音楽]
革命だと思ってる俺この家のなんかあれ
でしょ工事の家庭とかもずっと撮ってたん
ですよねバッチリ撮ってるんで
細かいそのエレベーターが出る過程みたい
なのはそちらでま近いですね出ると思うん
でちょっとぜひチェックしてみてください
ちょっと早速エレベーター乗ってみるね
はいというわけで早速エレベーター塗って
みたいと思います4階からのエレベーター
の扉こんな感じですはいその
家とは思えんエレベーターそれもなんか
めっちゃかっこいいこれさこれ扉とかも
新しくしたこれ全部新しいですよなんか
めっちゃかっこよくねエレベーターで黒
って珍しくない珍しいやっぱりね3億円の
お家なんでちょっとゴージャスをイメージ
にするってことでちょっと黒とかですね
[音楽]
これねエレベーター何がすごいかって4階
建てたからこの扉を4箇所に作ったわけ
でしょそれは時間もかかる
わじゃあ早速乗ってみようと思いますこれ
がボタンだねめっちゃわかりやすいやん
普通のビルのエレベーターとかと設定も
上とか下とかないんですよ普通に
ボタンが1個ポツンてあるだけこれ押せば
エレベーターが来てくれるって感じです
家にやるってすごいな
お来た
[音楽]
エレベーターだー
ご覧ください皆さん人の家に人の家に
エレベーター上がります
すげー
すげーこれさもちろん移動も楽になるん
ですけどもなんせYouTuberなので
私エレベータードッキリとかエレベーター
に24時間生活とかっていくんですよ自分
の家で最強あなんか色々書いてありますね
これ3つBC&キッチンエレベーター店員
は3名で200キロまで乗れると200
キロ乗れれば大抵のものは運べるんじゃ
ないかな
すげえちゃんと鉄にまである何これ
嬉しい
え待ってなんか
待って
誰かー
誰か
待ってなんか暗くなったんだけど
なんか暗くなったちょっと
待ってやばいやばい
何何何今の何もボタン押せなかったでしょ
何もしてなかった
ほらあのやっぱりずっとわかりついてると
もったいないじゃん
お疲れ様でした
省エネなのねそうそうそうそうなるほどね
素晴らしいね
ちゃんと
節電というかここさあ磁石なら初めて知っ
たわ
ほらこれで
磁石じゃんなんかエレベーターっぽく
ちゃんと
鏡になってるねここの鏡だね
すげー
天井も明るくておしゃれめっちゃ撮影映え
しますねなんかボタンのフォントもなんか
若干押されぶってる気がするんだよなぁ
これが閉じ込められた時の緊急ボタンです
[音楽]
みんなこれ家の中よビルじゃないですよお
家人のお家がこうなってるこれ
すごいんですよ結構はいというわけで早速
ちょっと移動してみたいと思います
閉じるボタンがないんですよねなんか親切
なんだよね例えば今4階にいるから3押す
と
うわー違うお部屋になってますこれ
[音楽]
いやそりゃそうだめっちゃ当たり前のこと
言ってる俺今2回押しますといやなんか
ごめんねみんな結構さ家にさちゃんとし
てるの夢だったんですよごめん結構興奮し
てる2階ですね
はいここ2階です1回押すとさらに1階に
行くと
[音楽]
1階に来ましたいやすげーいやー結構マジ
で嬉しいぞ
物の運びが楽になるなんか本当に僕大きい
と思っててこれは本当にようやく3億円の
お家がしっかりなんかもう実用性MAXで
動けるようになったなって気がします
うわーやばいいですか
[拍手]
安全センスを使うのこれを押してみても
いいですかこれで押すと他の回で何か音が
するらしいからちょっと俺下行くから10
秒後で押して10秒後に起こします
地震とかで止まった時エレベーターまず
怖いんだよね
[音楽]
何してんの何してんの急にしろってもう
その
ボタンですよちょっとどういうこと
安全装置
ベロしてますすいません
[拍手]
[音楽]
エレベーターおもろ
押した
押してる
え死んだ
[音楽]
死んだ
よかったなんでそんな心電図止まるような
音なるの
連打するな
安全装置をしたちゃんと押しました
ならないです連打もやったしこう長押し
めちゃくちゃ連打してたしなんか長押しし
たらあの心電図止まる感じになってたから
ねいやマジですすごいねはいというわけで
3億円の大津の最後の
鍵となるエレベーターが完成したのでまた
動画の幅が広がったりとかものなんか
飛び込みそして移動が楽になると思います
300円